oh come on batman
you used to be fun
don't you remember
fun
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
well here we are less than a week away
from the release of batman all right no
sorry
the
batman which is how my brain chooses to
deal
with that nonsense although somebody
suggested on twitter that maybe it
should be pronounced kind of the way
christian bale would have said it so the
batman
either way i got i feel like mocking the
duh i'm sorry and if you don't like the
idea of me having fun with batman you
ain't gonna like this video because
i remember when batman used to be fun
and i miss it
it's
really frustrating
as someone who does like batman to be
told continuously by people who like
these very specific
dark gritty miserable version of batman
that i clearly don't understand the
character first of all the character has
been around for decades and decades and
decades of time in so many variations in
so many reiterations there is literally
no such thing as a single definitive
version of batman there are tons and if
you do like this grim gritty version of
batman that it looks like we're getting
yet again
you're probably extremely happy
for me though i'm sick of it now like
i don't want to just leave it at that
because
that's the easy thing to do is for me
just to go ugh i don't like the dark and
gritty brutal batman anymore and this
looks like more of that
because the thing is again
i am old enough to recognize how we got
here
and i get it
because
for the last
over 30 years now
every time batman has done particularly
well
it's nearly always been
leaning
into the darkness and avoiding
the light aspects of the character now
the first thing to understand is that
lighter touches doesn't mean
adam west not that there was anything
wrong with adam west as batman either
but i'm saying you don't have to go to
that end you don't have to do
schumacher's batman and robin to get
lighter with the toe now kind of
illustrate it as i go along but as i
said i do recognize how things got this
way you can kind of kick things off with
the general darkening of comic book
characters in general during the 80s but
then in specific we've got
frank miller's work with the dark knight
returns and batman year one which went
for a more grounded more down in the
muck
just darker take on the character and
not a bad one and not an unfitting one
either
but that was sort of
instance one
of going darker with the character
really
going over well with people
that got reinforced in 89 with the first
tim burton batman which is a movie that
i like and is certainly visually on the
dark side it's got a very gothic
aesthetic
and then batman returns went too far
into dark they let tim burton get a
little too twisted with that one uh and
you know what i was gonna say fans
didn't like it i'm not sure if that's
true parents sure didn't because it was
being marketed with kids toys and
mcdonald's happy meals they weren't
happy and i can't say i blame them that
much for that but
the response to that was to bring in
joel schumacher batman forever and then
batman and robin batman forever did
pretty well i don't
like i was a little bit too young to be
plugged into fan response i liked it at
the time and i'm a mild defender of it
or at least aspects of it
but definitely whatever goodwill there
was was gone when batman and robbie came
out and so it's natural
for things to get pushed to the far
other side
of batman and robin and thus we get the
christopher nolan batman trilogy
starting with batman begins we continue
on through there and also during this
time it's worth noting that well the
comics in general have continued to get
massively uh dark and grim and gritty so
that trajectory went on unabated but
we've also got editions like the batman
arkham games very well designed very
well executed very popular video games
which also lean heavily into the darker
interpretation of batman so now in
addition to having kicked off the darker
batman comics are more successful and
now reinforced it with initially darker
batman movies and then well okay we went
too far but then you pull it back and
everybody rebelled against batman and
robin now we're reinforcing christopher
nolan no definitely the darker is the
way to go and now we have an additional
reinforcement mechanism with the batman
arkham games and it's very easy to see
why it has been so long
for us to get
a batman
who was fun
here's one of the things that's
frustrating for me though
even some of the things i've cited
were dark
but still fun
that first tim burton batman as i said
visually and aesthetically
very dark
joker was a lot of fun
and then
batman returns i mentioned there is fun
to be had but bit on the twisted side so
in terms of mixed response i get it
but then when we even get to the
christopher nolan trilogy which was so
you know welcomed and resounding
overwhelming praise it's dark again it's
more realistic like yeah but it still
had fun
watching bruce pretend to be a rich jerk
those scenes were fun
scarecrow was fun
lucious fox and the banter in his scenes
with bruce wayne
was fun
yeah you know cave diving
expecting to run into much gunfire in
these caves while the film overall
was a bit dark grounded might be the
better word but if you're gonna do
grounded and more realistic with
something as fantastic as superheroes it
is by necessity gonna be somewhat more
dark because the standard operating mode
of superheroes is to basically have as
few consequences as possible if you're
going realistic you have to bear out
consequences it automatically makes it
darker
the dark knight
while getting darker
i'm saying the word dark a lot i hope
you didn't make a drinking game out of
that if you did i'm sorry go get some
water but
that one yeah
it's darker than batman begins
and the joker
is
kind of twisted
but again
he's fun
he's having fun
and that is infectious that was also
part of what was going on with scarecrow
he was kinda having fun with what he did
so it's not necessarily that i need a
batman who is joking and having fun
though i don't have a problem with that
either but somebody
needs to be
because when we got to the dark knight
rises
bane wasn't fun
like him or love him he's not fun
particularly not this uh iteration of
him he's very self-serious he's kind of
dour
he doesn't seem to be he's taking all
that much enjoyment out of he seems to
take a little enjoyment out of breaking
the bat
but not nearly anything comparable
to the joker or even scarecrow
and then
we got batman v superman which i know
some people really love
but grant me this
it's not fun
now in its defense it's not trying to be
it is trying to be
dark and serious and ponderous and be
about these two men
neither of whom really
should be in this situation but they are
just going to go at it it is a sense of
fate and inevitability determined just
by the title alone if nothing else that
things are going to come to that clash
whether anyone wants it or not but
the
only person who seems to be having any
degree of fun
maybe
lex luthor
but the performance unfortunately
doesn't gel with everything else cause
unlike say the heath ledger joker it's
not even properly contrasting with the
world around it he's supposed to
actually
exist in this world he's a successful
tech mogul in this world so him being
that out of place in terms of his
responses and the way he's going about
things actually feels off as opposed to
heath ledger's joker who was disruptive
and felt disruptive and that was the
point of the character
but really nobody was having fun in
batman v superman
and then
came justice league now joss whedon's
cut did try and inject some fun
it didn't work because it was working
off the initial work done by snyder and
by a series that wasn't built to be fun
it was built to be huge and operatic and
tragic in most aspects and trying to
inject fun into that
it didn't take it it kind of rejected it
felt super out of place
even while some of the individual
moments at least to me were kind of fun
and enjoyable and nice or even funny
they didn't fit with this
story in this movie in this world that
was built to tell
grand sweeping
tragic stories
and then when snyder came in to do the
snyder cut of justice league
which is a much better movie
it's not fun
it's over four hours of
incredible seriousness it works
certainly heck a lot better than the
injected levity from whedon worked in
terms of a cohesive piece of art
definitely
but it's also not fun
and
there's nothing that i see
about the batman in terms of trailers
promotional art
none of this seems fun
not even selena looks like she's having
that much fun which was about the one
way that dark knight rises tried to have
some fun was with catwoman but she was
superfluous to a lot of what was going
on so it didn't do much
ultimately but
part of what really irritates me about
this and again look maybe the movie's
good maybe the movie is fun maybe the
movie's great maybe i'll love it
i'm not saying it'll be bad
i'm saying i'm tired
and i think the tipping point for me was
when i saw the riddler
and
more emphasis was put on him in the lead
up in the promotion in the marketing
because
with the possible exception of the joker
i can't think of any other
batman villain
who should be more defined by being
fun
than the riddler
his entire gimmick
is games
games are supposed to be fun for
somebody for him if nobody else
but they seem to have done this
amalgamation of john doe from 7 and
jigsaw and yes you can claim well jigsaw
did games
i know he said i want to play a game
those weren't games
those were twisted traps and the guy's
morality was a mess and
again the saw movies are not fun
i know they have their fans but
fun is not the selling point
and the idea of taking a character like
the riddler
someone who
is obsessed with what is ultimately a
game
and removing all the sense of fun
i don't get it
and what's extra frustrating about me is
we're not that far out from having had a
recent example
that i'm not saying i necessarily want
to be the template but it showed that
you can keep the fun and still be dark
that was gotham
now i know gotham wasn't for everybody
but i loved gotham
and the shortest answer i can give you
as to why
is because
it did the dark stories it did the
twisted ideas it did the malevolent and
brutal characters that are the popular
way of doing anything related to batman
these days
but it also kept the fun it kept the
camp
there was a phrase that my partner liz
and i would say with gotham with
watching it because i got her into it
too
things would happen
that doesn't make sense but you know
what it makes gotham sense
because it was a vibe
it was a feel it was an embrace of the
ridiculousness
and i think that's part of the thing is
that this darkness this brutality goes
hand in hand with this
lifting up and this idea of
realistic ground it don't let it be too
silly because we're taking it so
seriously we can't let the silly stuff
from the comics bleed into this but the
silliness
is part of what's fun
especially
with the villains the villains being
silly in
contrast to how dark and dour batman is
is part of what's fun
if everybody's just dark and miserable
then you've decided to make the entire
thing just this one note
no variance it's fine to have a
prominent
idea a prominent mood a prominent
palette but to have it literally be the
only thing the entire movie does
i'm sorry for me that's boring
so i look at something like gotham that
had
dark twisted stuff in it people being
tortured losing limbs being murdered and
in some very very nasty ways a lot of
these characters are flat out psychotic
but you know what
they all had a sense of fun jerome was
having fun
ed was having fun oswald when he wasn't
having a temper tantrum was having
fun
these people liked what they did it's
just what they did was terrible but it
gave you a reason to have fun
and what's really
even more so than the existence of
someone like gotham where i'm like
why can't we have
anything more like that i know i said
that there isn't a single definitive
version of batman
but you know what the closest thing we
have to a definitive version of batman
is you know what version of batman
most fans will point to and say
that's kind of the platonic ideal of
batman
where everything is just perfectly
balanced no one element is dominating
too much it's not overcampified until it
becomes schumacher it's not so dark and
dour that it's batman v superman
and that is the batman animated series
now i don't know if
warner brothers or any of the directors
they get are afraid to take inspiration
from that because it's animated do they
think the only reason it got away with
having a mix of silly and dark
was because it was a cartoon
i don't know
maybe
but that show
was fun
most of the villains
were having fun
half of me wants to strangle you and
what does the other half want to hit you
with a truck
we used to date
and things
could get dark things could get rough
you can look to the mask of the phantasm
as a case study
yeah that delves into batman's issues
his psyche his damage
but it's also fun
i don't know
why we can't
have a fun
batman anymore
and again
i want to be wrong
i want when i go and see
the batman
i want to come out and go
boy my concerns were dumb
i had my head up my own ass that was
great
i
want that to happen
i don't have much reason to believe that
it will
though
it's been a long time
since a
major heavily marketed
especially superhero related thing has
severely
beaten my expectations
they've surprised me in you know story
twists but
i don't remember the last time where i
saw something and went okay overall vibe
for it seems to be this and i was wrong
the last time i remember that happening
was the first wonder woman which
i was convinced was going to suck
and it didn't
i like it a lot
and i want that to happen with the
batman but the only way for it to happen
for me at this point is if all the
marketing has been misleading which
would in turn be its own problem
because if the marketing is accurate
which at this point given the
consistency of every single piece of
concept art poster every trailer etc
is very consistently hitting the exact
same note
i have a hard time believing that this
isn't exactly what they're selling me
and what they're selling me
is something that isn't
fun
and i don't
jive with the idea
that fun makes something
less worthy
less
meaningful less adult what
what is it that makes some people think
that being an adult means never having
fun
i don't know
but whatever it is that gets people into
that mindset
i'm not there and i don't ever want to
be
i want fun
i like batman
i would like a fun batman movie
because it's been a long time
since i've been looking forward
to really almost anything
batman related
because it's not fun anymore
it can be
the pieces are there
being fun is not a fundamental betrayal
of who batman is as a property or as a
character
they've just been treating it like it is
for way too dang long
just kind of had to get that off my
chest
i'm sure tons of people are going to
disagree with me
if the reaction to my
uh general sense of i'm not so sure
about this when i did a reaction to the
batman trailer if if the rest must have
any indication i'm about to get shredded
in the comments by a certain
group of fans but
uh we'll see
even if you think i'm 100 off base and
absolutely wrong please just don't be
rude
because i don't actually just delete
comments that disagree with me i just
delete ones that are rude and mean and
use personal attacks or threats
those i delete so don't do that your
comment will stay there even if you
disagree with me so whatever your
thoughts are as long as you can be not
rude about it drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it
like share subscribe if you don't hate
me after this ramble you can support me
on patreon link in the description as
well as well as the other stuff that i
do no real pressure though
because at the end of the day
agree with me or not you are actually
the council
i'm just running the meetings
so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
patreon shout outs thank you to turok
shane ross oliver b melinda walters
robin powell for nobulax the poodle
edelon tracy scrabbit dharma michael
doyle vincent paul bartolucci angry
casper adam lefty taylor robin moore
shayla gourley and bookworm
you can support me as well hear me
mispronounce your name
sure i got some of those wrong
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
you
[Music]